happy memo day everybody you know I just
finished breakfast across the street
with my friend from New York and we
decided to bring him by here to maybe
talk about some of the things that are
in the news I am joined today by very
stable genius former White House
communications director Anthony
scaramouche II the man the myth the
legend the mooch there is breaking news
the House Intelligence Committee has
released a damning memo suggesting the
FBI and DOJ colluded with Democrats to
undermine and spy on the Trump
presidential campaign we will get
Anthony's first public comments on the
memo then we will find out whether
President Trump really is a very stable
genius who the good guys and the bad
guys are in the White House how the
Muller investigation ends and where the
Trump train steams off to next
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Nolt show
[Music]
so is there anything going on in the
news today I don't know but before we
get to all of that before we get to that
folks listen I know that Anthony scare
Moochie
he's a hustler this guy has a lot of
talents he's worked on a lot of skills
in his life he's bounced from career to
other aspects of industry into politics
back into finance and you know how he
does that it's because he's got a lot of
skills and you should too the skill
share is an online learning platform
with over 18,000 classes in design
business technology and more you can
take classes in graphic design social
media marketing illustration mobile
photography communications
choose just to name a few they have
wonderful wonderful classes whether
you're trying to deepen your
professional skill set start a side
hustle maybe make it all the way up to
the White House or just explore a new
passion skill share is there to keep you
learning and thriving this is really
good I'm taking one now on time
management because you know it takes a
lot of my day to not write any books
then and sometimes I don't have time to
not write a book at the end of the day
that's why if you have time management
or you can stop procrastinating that's
just one of the classes available on
Skillshare they have a million gazillion
really good ones over 18,000 courses
available join the millions of students
already learning on Skillshare today
with a special offer just for my
listeners get two months of Skillshare
for just 99 cents that is less than $1
that is basically free you get two
months for 99 cents there is no reason
for you not to take advantage of this
this is one of the great benefits we try
to be philanthropists here give back to
society build up good citizens be a good
citizen learn something go get two
months for 99 cents Skillshare is
offering michael no show listeners two
months of unlimited access to 18,000
classes for 99 cents to sign up go to
Skillshare comm / michael mi CH AE l
again go to Skillshare comm slash
michael to start your two months now
Marshall what is it Gil sure comm slash
Michael Anthony thank you for being here
the mooch is here sure that I'm gonna go
on Skillshare he's gotta go now we're
gonna leave new skills you introduced me
improperly though I'm actually an
unstable non GU those are the coffee
mugs of my
families made up for me me and the
unstable non Sunday mornings I got to
drink a coffee out of a non stay boy non
genius or unstable non genes so you're
gonna have to send me one of those that
sounds almost as good as the leftist
here's tumblr that's and there are a lot
of leftist tears pouring out today by
the way I'm super jealous of you by the
way I mean the fact that I've written
three books and haven't been able to
sell one book other than the ones that I
bought myself of course my basement in
the basement you're writing about
nothing and selling hundreds of
thousands of books well your you might
be an unstable non genius I am a non
writing author so there's a lot of
inversion that goes on in these in these
great skills we were having breakfast
when this memo stuff broke yeah we were
having breakfast when the news broke
Andrew McCabe confirmed that no FISA
warrant would have been sought without
the steal dossier information which was
ordered and paid for by the Hillary
Clinton campaign and the Democrat Party
is there a conspiracy at the FBI and
other agencies to take down Donald Trump
again I'm not sure I'm not a conspiracy
person myself so I'm not gonna say that
there's a conspiracy but if you if you
think about the events today you have to
ask yourself with the right protocols
and checks and balances are in place in
these situations to make sure that the
politicization I said that properly of a
agency that is supposed to be as
non-political as possible to ensure the
integrity of our system and our
political system and our legal system oh
boy I think they've got to probably
tighten that up a lot and this was the
president was exonerated today on a lot
of things that he'd be saying back in
March Michael which you know that's
absolutely right he was exonerated
people were spewing fake news I know you
know we talked of CNN is already trying
to spin this thing they're saying it's a
Republican memo it's this or that
they're so frustrated that their lies
and called out if President Trump
observed this he said top officials at
the FBI and DOJ politicized the sacred
investigative process in favor of
Democrats and against Republicans do you
think that means if he's exonerated
today that it's time to fire Muller
that's time to end this investigation
again I I don't know I mean I'm not
inside the White House anymore and I'm
not part of those strategy sessions but
Mike
tells me would be a bad move to fire
Mahler primarily because what ends up
happening the error and if you not not
to bore your listeners or viewers with
history but when they fired Archibald
Cox on the on that great Saturday
evening massacre I think that point the
administration into a tailspin I think
they completely lost their footing I
think the president's I'm pretty strong
footing right now
I saw reports this morning that he's got
a forty nine percent approval rating
post State of the Union address I
thought was a spectacular from the State
of the Union address and so he's got a
lot of things going his way momentum
wise the economy the right policies on
the economy the right policies for the
middle class and lower middle class
families and so all of that together in
the soup I would say don't fire Muller I
believe that there's absolutely no
collusion there I know the President
believes that no collusion with Russia
right now what they will say well did
the Russians interfere in the election
okay Mike Pompeo says that they did I'll
take the CIA director at his word he's a
high integrity guy I never met with many
of our life that's my point they
probably interfered with our elections
for as long as they have been in
existence so that's probably 1917 to
today unfortunately that's the world
that we live in but to say that the
Republican Party's candidate colluded
with the Russians I don't believe that I
was there I you know I was there for
eleven days in the White House but I was
there for 18 months on the campaign as a
member of the executive transition team
and I didn't see anything like that and
so I'm pretty confident more than how
they comment the president will be
exonerated but here's the issue we're in
a very highly polarized society the
president's been right about a lot of
things and stylistically his adversaries
don't like him and so he fires Muller
bill that will be a touch and firestorm
that he doesn't need right now the
momentum is his friend I would leave the
guy alone that's right because it would
also distract from the cycle of we have
evidence Democrats and Barack Obama's
government acted improperly why
overshadow that news cycle and throw
yourself and expose yourself tomorrow I
don't lose anything any need to do that
and I don't
Robert Muller personally but the
president also said the New York Times a
few weeks ago maybe a month ago did he
expect him to treat him fairly the
people that know Robert Muller
personally think he is a fair and
judicious person I think that what
happened today is relates to the memo
will probably make him even more
cautious yeah and more judicious in
terms of treating this matter before the
president so by large it was a good day
for America because what we have to do
is we have to get back to what the Daily
wire wants what you want personally what
I want personally and what's in the
Federalist Papers we got to get back to
the government serving the people and
the government not losing sight of that
where they think that the people are
really serving them well we've been
gradually flipping that as we've become
more of a status Society and we need to
return it back to the individuals and
certainly the president and his
administration we're trying to do that I
remember I had the privilege of meeting
with Justice Scalia before he died and
he said that the greatest threat to
Liberty in the Republic are these
overwhelming unaccountable agencies out
of the executive branch that don't have
a lot of oversight that govern as they
will without democratic checks tom
Fitton of Judicial Watch said quote you
had Hillary Clinton in the Democratic
Party try to hide the fact that they
gave money to GPS fusion fusion GPS to
create a dossier which was used by their
allies in the Obama administration to
convince a court misleadingly by all
accounts to spy on Trump on the Trump
team President Trump tweeted out that
quote do people need to go to jail for
this and will they I don't know they
they might but but here's what I would
say and again I don't like even during
the campaign I never attacked Secretary
Clinton personally I never attacked
President Obama personally I really just
wanted to talk about the policies but I
do think it's fair to talk about the
facts okay and if you go back to July of
2016 it was discovered that Debra
Wasserman Schultz and secretary
Clinton's team did certain things to
manipulate the process and manipulate
senator Bernie Sanders out of the
process okay and that probably cost
through the election because Millennials
that wanted to support him they didn't
cross over as aggressively to support
her once she got the nomination
they thought the system was rigged then
Donna Brazile who's gonna be joining me
tonight on the Bill Maher show on HBO
basically wrote a book about this and so
there are facts here where these people
like to take the P under the shell and
they like hiding it from the American
people and so so you have to be very
very worried about that but there's a
there's an assent for power there's a
quest or a lust for power where people
think they can curve the rules to get
power to bend towards them right oh and
that's very unamerican and so so I'm not
saying anybody has to go to jail but it
does seem like the processes that are
put in place and these agencies need to
be tightened yeah that's right it's a
good analogy the shell game of people
just like from Coney Island or something
that's what you're seeing at these
agencies along it's just really unfair
because because you're relying on the
integrity of this system the United
States has so many valuable assets we
have our great people all the great
human capital we have the great
resources of the nation the fact that
we're we become so powerful because
we're basically an island continent we
were protected for hundreds of years
from these big oceans all of this great
stuff but the number one thing that we
have and this is what Justice Scalia
would say and I I knew him reasonably
well is that we have a system that we
put in place that checks power the
balance of power written into the
Constitution the the the the judicial
branch legislative branch and the
executive power each are checking each
other
subordinates individuals to the law
it's what Cicero once said 2200 years
ago that we are slaves to the law on
order to be free and if you think about
the foundational principles of the
country we put ourselves in that
position and so you don't like seeing
people subverting that for their own
personal gain tear the whole edifice
down if it can because because you know
Reagan said and I was probably 22 at the
time that he said it so it's 32 years
ago Reagan said that you're always 25
years away from potentially losing your
democracy if you don't in bold and power
and educate the youth you don't explain
to them the beauty of the system that
they're living in certainly the system
has flaws but it is the best system
Churchill once said about democracy is
that it
it's a horrific form of government until
you consider all the other forms except
for all the other ones we've ever tried
and and so he's right and this is a very
very precious thing that we have and so
we've got to check people that are in
power and these agencies unfortunately
because they don't have they're not part
of the orbit of that check and balance
system sometimes things can go go awry
they're a little extra constitutional
they seem to subvert a lot of the
constitutional order that we that has
ruled the country first they have yeah
by and large been extremely helpful I
mean I'm not ever gonna you're never
gonna see me who lived in New York
during 9/11 rail on the FBI or their
grill and our counterterrorism units I'm
not gonna do anything like that I think
the president's tweet more or less spoke
for himself he knows that the rank and
file are very solid that's right but
he's just saying that these processes
that were put in place particularly if
that that steele memo or whatever that
was that oppositional research led to
all of that banana's stuff that was
happening that was actually very unfair
to the system and so listen we got to
come up with a better way to organize
ourselves so that doesn't happen again
I've talked to other administration
officials they say the the damn shame
about this is that because of the
political appointees of these agencies
the Obama era appointees of these
agencies all of the good agents at the
FBI or DOJ they're being unfairly marred
even though they're good agents it's
these political appointees that have
acted inappropriately and used the
government for political purposes well I
mean listen so it'll change I mean
here's the greatest thing about our
country we've had to heal ourselves many
times we healed ourselves after the
Civil War we held ourselves after the
Great Depression
we've healed ourselves after the
Watergate situation and so what we'll do
is we'll come together and hear all
ourselves we got a lot of great things
that are happening right now today they
printed a 2.9 percent wage increase so
middle class wages and lower middle
class wages are going up first time in
nine years this is the first time since
the Great Recession I got trained as an
economist I can tell you that our 2006
wages have still not reached that
high-water mark and we're 12 years out
from there and so we've got to get these
families
back on the grid I don't know if you saw
the manufacturing data we've had a huge
manufacturing surge we're manufacturing
now at the level that we were in 2004
before we went into that great slippage
and so these are super positive things
for the country what happened yesterday
is the tax plan went into effect and so
there's more disposable income for each
American it's not crumbs $2,000 is a
meaningful amount of money in somebody's
pocket if they're making $50,000 a year
and so hopefully that will go towards
investment savings fortifying their
family's lifestyle all these things are
super positive and so we should try to
focus on the positives write in and hand
check and correct as we've always done
in this nation when something is going
wrong we got to correct it but what I
what I would say to my adversary is my
political adversaries both inside my own
party and my adversaries outside the
party is that we should have an
unconditional love for this country and
stop right there and we're all part of
the same family and so let's knit
ourselves back together and get this
stuff right because the American people
are really hungry for that and what do
you think so there's a lot of fake news
that isn't reporting any of these
important statistics and important
things have happened in the country you
yourself have been the victim of some
fake news CN n ran a total hit job on
you and they lost three reporters
because of it they even had to admit it
who do you think when you look around
the political observers right now we're
looking at this Trump administration
this Trump moment who we're offering the
best analysis analysis where you could
rely on and say okay this is where the
administration is going this is where
the country is going prison companies
yeah I'll give you guys out huge
probably you guys do an amazing job
you're really trying to get to the truth
you know very close to Sean Hannity I do
think that there are people at CNN MSNBC
and other news outlets individuals
inside there that are fairly objective
that are trying to do the right thing
you know what I don't like it are these
labels okay so if you're at CNN you're
automatically a trump aider and you're
automatically super liberal there are
pockets of people in there Jason Miller
as an example as a paid contributor to
CNN he was the communications director
there's a little bit of
he was communications director for one
day I was the communications director
for 11 days you know we're close
personal friends
he's very Pro Trump so so you have
pockets of people in these places that
are actually trying to be objective
trying to do do a good job in it when I
say be objective I'm saying they're Pro
Trump people say okay well he's not
obviously being subjective I don't mean
it that way I mean like let's look for
the truth let's try to focus on policies
that are gonna help the American people
common-sense policies
let's not overly politicize the
situation and I think there are people
that doing that you you brought up CNN I
actually have a pretty good relationship
with CNN and Jeff Zucker and some of the
news anchors there even the news anchors
that don't share my political view
whether it's a Jake Tapper or a Chris
Cuomo but I what I will say though is
that the story that they wrote about me
was singly source they had one person do
you know the source was uh you know I
don't obviously you know you know I have
an inkling of who I think it may have
been but here's the problem with all
this stuff these sources are all
anonymous they they leak like sibs
this is a business practice inside the
swamp that people do you know some of
the people are sore at me because I
speak my mind and I put myself on the
record and actually declare what I think
of people they're doing the same thing
to me except the problem is yeah they're
doing it off the records or doing it
through cutouts or doing it through all
of these like backstabbing Shiva Sh sort
of ways of doing things and I know your
generation the millennial generation is
sort of tired of this nonsense you know
they don't they don't like it it's not
serving anybody to do that it's not
beneficial to the country and so what
I'd rather do is as an entrepreneurs
let's disrupt let's hack the
communications model if you're gonna hit
me for 13 straight months and think I
don't know that you're the guy hitting
me you know it's a joke okay so but I'll
hit you back and I'll hit you back
directly okay and maybe we can get it to
stop maybe we can get you to knock it
off but what I'm not gonna do is just
sit there and take it so in the CNN case
I told those three guys don't write the
story it's completely untrue I've got a
deep enough pocket where if you write
the story there's gonna be there's gonna
be a big commotion about it I'm not the
typical political operative it's
probably why I got fired so quickly
because I didn't handle the situation
the way a political operative would
I handled it the way a business
executive would or an entrepreneur why
would a political operative handle it
differently
only the man wastes liquor they would
have been as surreptitious as the other
people they would have done the whole
howdy doody you know Richie Cunningham
thing golly gee - everybody's face and
then they would have operated behind the
scenes you know I did what a business
executive would do it's okay here's what
we're doing we got to change the culture
for some bad actors here the first you
got to do and yet bad actors and the
cultures you got to ask them to stop it
and you got to identify immediately the
ones that think you're kidding you got
to remove those people from the field
and then by and large other people start
to Mel to gether okay so in the process
of doing that and I was handling it too
aggressively these are miming listen
I've made probably 10 phone books of
mistakes in my life but probably five
phone books and mistakes over those 11
days right I was just handling it too
aggressively do you think because
there's something very refreshing about
Donald Trump Donald Trump comes in he's
very aggressive he doesn't beat around
the bush he doesn't do in that Vanity
Fair interview which is very
entertaining and interesting interviewer
you refer to
Reince Priebus as a Howdy Doody or
Richie Cunningham Donald Trump doesn't
do that so it served him well do you not
why didn't it serve you well I'm not the
president you know I was his comms
director I needed to be a little bit
more depth I needed to be a little bit
more subtle
I needed to be less aggressive I
probably should have taken the
president's marching orders less
seriously less clinically and you know
listen I mean at the end of the day I've
made it a lot of mistakes I had I owned
them I apologized for them and I've
moved on but what I'm not gonna do is
break ranks with the president because
he's he's a good man he's doing a very
good job stylistically at times he would
probably be better served if he dialed
into a different style once in a while
but at the end of the day his report
card his record is gonna speak for
itself
we've got a Super Bowl coming up this
weekend Bill Parcells who whose Protege
Bill Belichick is arguably one of the
best coaches in NFL history these guys
have a great line my record is my record
I'll let my record say whether or not
I'm a good NFL coach or not and I think
that's how the president feels about his
presidency right now
he's not just an unbelievable first-year
you just look at the data the most
conservative first-year modern and
recognize from national security context
labor regulations in the board
regulations on different businesses he's
allowed disappointments judicial
appointments he's allowed these
businesses to grow and prosper he set an
agenda that's pro-business friendly
which will lead to wage growth the tax
cut is having this unbelievable
consequence that I don't think anybody
truly expected secretary minuchin and
secretary Ross said last week in Davos
that they didn't expect the magnitude of
the businesses large and small that
we're offering up higher bonus payouts
higher minimum wages more capital
investments this is all a result of
making America's tax rate more
competitive so what are we learning from
the president policy matters we're
learning from the president that he said
before the State of the Union that his
heart and soul is in the thing and he
realizes as president as a politician is
to be way more compassionate because
there are millions of people's lives
that are at stake in terms of where the
decisions are being made so just think
about what he did with the taxes
millions upon millions of people around
the world have benefited from but CNN
told me everyone's taxes were going up
every mall the news media in New York
told some taxes are go some some of
that's actually a you know look my taxes
went up I'm gonna clean my taxes
whenever I'm in a blue state and so the
deduction the lack of deductibility was
not offset by the decrease in federal
marginal tax rate eighty percent of
americans get it but yeah but the more
important thing is it wasn't designed
for you or me necessarily it was really
designed for frankly the people that I
grew up with to give them more
disposable income in their pockets and
so I think it by Lord's been gonna be a
resounding success absolutely and just
the corporate cut that alone and make it
a great rating Michaels making the
country more competitive obviously and
you see it even the IMF admits that do
you think that the president is being
served by his team I think you get
credit for knocking out some of his
advisers who might not have been serving
him very well when you left do you think
he's being served by his team now were
the good guys who were the bad guys well
listen I mean III do I think general
Kelley is done a good job he's uh he
seems
again from a distance I don't I don't I
don't talk to general Kelly but it seems
like they're very well organized it
seems like they have they've got a good
message I think they're gonna come out
with a solution on the daca situation
then they're gonna turn their focus to
health care I think that the the team
that I know some of them there so
they're from the campaign whether it's
Jared or Ivanka or somebody like Kelly
and Conway I know they love the
president or trimming loyal to him
they're great messengers for the
president there was an article today
which I share with a lot of my friends
about the successes that Jared is
already having in the Middle East in
terms of the design and implementation
of that strategy and the eventual unveil
meant of the Middle East peace process I
think it'll be unique it'll be a lot
it'll be disruptive like so many things
that the president's willing to do that
other politicians frankly weren't
willing to do I remember earlier on in
the administration some of president
Trump's former advisors say Steve Bannon
for instance was reported widely to be
criticizing Jared Kushner criticizing
Ivanka has the president made a decision
on which way his administration and his
staffing is gonna go yeah well obviously
I mean listen I mean here's the problem
with all that like he was trying to
split the administration between
globalists and nationalists and and
Steve is also this guy that was trying
to go for 120 percent of something where
you know the Ronald Reagan aphorism is
you got to go for 80 percent of
something and hope that you can get that
and reach a compromise with the other
side because that's the way the founders
put the system in place so that sort of
divisive nough stat unnecessary leaking
that in turn s and warfare the dropping
of people's personal wise and the
innuendo and all of that stupid nonsense
that was going on inside the White House
that's certainly down and so I think you
know I give a lot of credit the general
Kelly and for the president going in
that direction do you think that we
talked about the tweeting when he goes
he Street tweets these things and it's
brash and I really like it I think it
really leads the media all around a lot
of people especially on the right has
critics on the right say he needs to
stop the tweeting go go into a closet
somewhere don't tweet just keep doing
what you're doing but stuff I do you
think
tweeting help summer at her no I I think
if the if the people that want him to
stop the tweeting got on television and
said I want you to treat more please
send out more tweets and send out
incessant tweets maybe then he wouldíve
enough maybe I'll put the phone back in
my pocket right so I have found even on
the campaign was it stopped the tweeting
the president will gonna shake his head
because he would say listen you're not
seeing what I'm seeing and what he was
seeing and you have to accept that this
is true some presidential historian will
write this about him you got to think
about the use of social media by a
seven-year-old man okay he the most
culturally tuned in I've got to give him
credit right and he's also great you got
to think about though his idioms and the
way messages to people there's always a
little bit of a twist
he's the Frank Sinatra of tweeting okay
and now you're not old enough to
remember Frank but I listened to a lot
of Frank but Frank had a personality
that he added to his music he was always
on key but you could always find him a
little slippage with the words or he
throw in an extra word that wasn't
necessarily in the lyrics and he would
do certain things that added his
charisma and Verve to the song and so
the President does that he's the Frank
Sinatra of tweeting you can always tell
for all we know he might be running
pharaoh's father we don't know who knows
he's definitely not Ronan Farrell's well
I'll take the over on that one but but
what I would say to you about about him
is that what he's tweeting you know it's
his tweets I think he could bees at
times more strategic you know I I if I
was sitting there with him I would say
listen let your advocates let your
surrogates excuse me both inside the
White House and outside the White House
do the job of defending you against some
of the nonsense you don't have to write
about people's facelifts you don't have
to write about people's personalities
let your media surrogates do that focus
on policy focus on things that you want
to get out there focus on trying to
bring the Democrats together on a dock a
deal things like that um but you know
listen he's not gonna he's not gonna
listen to anybody on that he's got great
media instincts he went from zero to the
American presidency in 17 months no one
in the history United State has ever
done that it's the toughest job
it's the most powerful job in the world
and there were a lot of qualified people
in 2016 that wanted that job and he
slayed every single one this is my
question I might not be old enough to
remember Frank Sinatra but I am old
enough to remember the time when the
billionaire who took over New York real
estate and casinos and television and
branding and then won the highest job in
the world on his first go at politics
defeated 16 of the best politicians in
the country then took down as a Clinton
I'm old enough to remember the time when
people thought he might be somewhat
intelligent I'm that's how old I am do
you is is the President as he says like
a very stable genius
well I mean look I mean like I said I
mean of course he's like a very stable
gene I mean this the funny stuff about
that when he's writing that you can
almost see the smirk ich frog face that
he makes while he's writing it because
he knows it's gonna set the hair on fire
for all these liberals you know but I'm
gonna tell you something about the
president okay I am old enough to
remember when dr. Martin Luther King's
holiday which was signed into law by
President Reagan wasn't appropriately
honored with the same respect as other
federal ''tis I'm old enough to remember
when I was a young guy on Wall Street
probably your age where Donald J Trump
and a group of leading New York
businessmen entrepreneurs and Wall
Street executives lobbied the New York
Stock Exchange with the rainbow
coalition which was led by the Reverend
Jesse Jackson to get the stock exchange
to close on Martin Luther King's
birthday and and people don't want to
give any credit for that because if you
greatest but you can find that on the
internet you can find the Reverend Jesse
Jackson saying great things about his
personality and you can you can find
that he's actually racially blind he's
colorblind he's a guy that really wants
people to do well and he's been a winner
his whole life you know I I you know
we're talking you're talking about the
Bill Cohen article this guy is like a
Michael Jordan he can he's not a choke
artist he will hit the shot I took a lot
of flack on that when they in the press
conference I said because I've seen him
do it okay and by the way he hit the
shot on the presidency a lot of guys
couldn't do that on his first try on his
first official try on his first try that
speaking of the smirk by the way going
back to seeing the smirk when Donald
Trump is tweeting them Ryan Lizza ended
your career at the White House you had a
phone call with Ryan Lizza from the New
Yorker
yeah I ended the maybe I I made the
mistake of trusting him so I have to
take personal responsibility for that
but he participated in it at least and
then a few months later he was booted he
was fired from his job for allegations
of sexual misconduct did it take a
crowbar to pry the grin from your face
when that occurred hey let me tell you
something you know I'm a human being and
so my reaction to his firing was okay
great he's not gonna be able to do to
other human beings what he did to me
there's a very malicious very nefarious
very evil doer I don't know what he did
at The New Yorker to get himself fired
but I know what he did to me so I know
what the personality type is the reason
why I'm a big believer in karma is that
you know something bad could happen to
you from a person like him and you say
oh well someday he'll get his and the
answer is of course he will because the
nefarious action that he perpetrated on
me he's gonna eventually cross the line
farther enough or further enough where
he gets smacked back and so I'm I'm glad
he lost his job and it's not like I'm
taking this like shot and Freud a
pleasure in it because what he did to me
was unconscionable how he kurtz from
media buzz said that his act towards me
he never seen anything like that in the
40 years that he's been in Washington a
journalist that would actually do that
to a White House official chief it was
some heavy well as you know President
Obama said say that you know they cut
one of his middle fingers off and
therefore they muted his expertise but
Rob was known to be a profane guy right
behind the scenes President to have the
table with steak knives with President
President Obama himself many others if
you think in your audience thinks I'm
the only person in the West Wing that's
had a little bit of a potty mouth from
time to time you know then you guys are
not on the same planet that I'm living
of course so what he did to me and the
way he wrote the story and if you listen
to the tape versus the story I'm
literally having a conversation with him
like I'm having it with you except it's
a little bit more neighborly his father
knew my dad for 50 years yeah he said
well he
said in the story that I'm lying about
that that's not that's you know I you
can interview my folks they know the
Lizza family forever
he is right about the fact that we
didn't know each other super well we had
met on the set of CNN he is right at it
but we were building a rapport with each
other and when I called him that night I
didn't think he would do that to me but
I am at that point in my life the White
House communications director and I
shouldn't be trusting journalists like
him or anybody for that matter no matter
what their last names are what they're
connected or my family or my
neighborhood I had to own that and so I
take personal responsibility for it but
here's the learning lesson for younger
people that are probably plugged into
your program own it but don't let it be
a millstone on your neck for the rest of
your life just move on just people you
have to always do in your life is
forgive yourself and drop the Millstone
don't live your life with regret don't
live in the past focus on the present
and the future and just make yourself
better every day
this gets to a point on a personal
question you graduated from Harvard Law
School you worked at Goldman Sachs you
founded two financial services companies
you turn them into big successes yet in
the public eye you are the mooch you are
the zany profane New Yorker that Ryan
Lizza writes about yeah same with Donald
Trump Donald Trump graduated from
Wharton he had massive professional
success he rose to the highest level in
the land and yet in the public eyes he's
this cartoon character Donald Trump
tweeting cough fa ha is there a
political advantage to playing a little
bit dumber or a little bit crazier than
your mark yeah well I mean there isn't
there isn't I mean I think what they try
to do and they're sometimes successful
and they've been less successful with
the president for a reason because of
his persistence and his resilience but
the move the playbook move is too
cartoonish cartoon of five people
especially for Republican yeah to
dimensionalize them call them racists I
mean that's like boom here until you're
autumn you're an auto racist Jesse
Jackson loves you you campaign for
Martin Luther King Day on the stock
exchange but you become a Republican
than you're racist you're a racist but
but the point is is that like if if I
have a voice that's credible and I did
go to the Harvard Law School and I'm
reasonably well-read and have a pretty
good idea about where the zeitgeist is
going at what policies make sense for
the country right at the end of the day
you really got to know me
less focus on left and right and I'm
more focused on right or wrong like
what's actually the right thing for the
country I'm a libertarian by nature more
than I am a conservative and so you
asked me about the marriage equality
movement I honestly do not care who
marries who and so for 15 years I've
been a gay rights activist the Liberals
will not give me any credit for that of
course because I've sided with the
President on so many issues and so so
I'm really an eclectic bag politically
okay I'm not really purely Streak
politically I'd rather like I said focus
on what's right or wrong
as opposed to left or right and I can
also back it up with a lot of content
that is a disaster for an adversary
because if I'm doing that that doesn't
work you've got to tell me that I'm the
situation gym tan laundry right that's
what I think Seth Meyers called me a
human pinky ring you've got to say that
I'm a gangsta from New York that is that
is slightly offensive I mean you know
I'm a guy I remember from MSNBC said I
was like a studio gangster or staged
gangster and I said look I'm an
italian-american you know that's like
really offensive
I don't know imagine if they said that
about any other ethnic group imagine if
they said it's it's crazy but you know
what let me tell you something you're a
fellow Italian or you're half Italian
yeah you can't bring it up because you
get no backup no we're good no one's
gonna back you up it's okay to put The
Sopranos out there and the Godfather on
for sure and you brought up Justice
Scalia and what Scalia would tell you
that he's a big believer in the First
Amendment as am i I don't care I own my
heritage and I don't care about it but
what I won't do is sit in the shame box
that my adversaries have built for me
what I won't do is allow them to
contextualize me the way they're trying
to I'm not gonna do that I'm gonna come
on your show I'm gonna go on Bill Maher
show tonight I'm gonna be with Chris
Cuomo boxing with them in the freezing
Fredo Elmo is what we call him here at
the Daily wire but sure is your friend
I'm really afraid of Cuomo he'll get up
to get upset about that but but but you
know listen and he has an ideological
view that's very different from mine
you grew up in a Democratic family I
grew up in a Republican family we see
the world differently
of course my view in your view is the
right view
wrong right but my point is we can
disagree and still be somewhat agreeable
with each other this whole nonsense
where the president's delivering the
results and nobody can stand and clap
and everyone's gonna have a you know
scowl on their faces you know it was
like a you know I was calling it
democratic detox instead of Botox right
de for Democrat they were all had the
same plastic like look on their faces
hey you know get over yourselves okay
they're doing that for the cameras
they're voting for the cameras so that
their base will say okay yeah yeah yeah
be part of the resistance resist this
guy they did this to Reagan and they did
it to Reagan even conservatives did it
to Reagan and the way conservatives are
doing it to Trump they did it to Reagan
early part of his of his terms as he was
delivering the result and they started
to realize the kind of guy that it
really was it was very hard to hit him
as much as they did but Reagan made a
very big gaffe before one of his
televised speeches where he was joking
around and he leaned into the microphone
he said we begin bombing
I've outlawed russia forever yeah and we
begin bombing in five minutes and so
everyone went crazy
it was very trumpian frankly you know oh
he's this he's that there were
protesters and all this other stuff but
he was a peace-loving man you know he
loved his family loved his country to
abolish nuclear what's great great
writer um they didn't give any credit
for his writing skills uh Reagan in his
own words if you have an interest in
that book it was one moment okay I'm
gonna book about his personality and
when you when you think about the
President or our current president he
just has a lot of common sense he's got
a lot of wisdom but he's a tough brawler
aggressive sort of a guy and he's doing
a great job and I particular what the
one observation the one nice thing that
I will say about Fredo on this program
Chris Cuomo your friend is the only time
I can watch Chris Cuomo is when you are
on his show and you guys are fun it is
some of the best TV that is out there it
is the only time I watched yeah I mean I
have I was a little bit too crazy from
Davos at four o'clock in the morning
yeah listen I mean we get along though I
mean at the end of the day um I do
disagree with him on the memo that just
came out and I do disagree with
everything else you know and I and I
tweeted out earlier today you can go on
my Twitter feed where you can see I'm
being interviewed by him in March
president saying that's been wiretapping
going on now Chris will parse that he'll
say well he said specifically it was him
and Trump Tower okay I understand that
but it's Twitter it's 140 characters
what he's hours a metonym for the
campaign that's my if that's that's the
point he's really just trying to say
more broadly that there was some
nefarious activity or a lack of a proper
procedures in place that led to some
politicized observation of people that
were involved in his campaign and so
listen we can debate about whether it's
right we can debate about whether it's
wrong but it doesn't seem right and if I
were the Democrats and I was a
Democratic strategist I would actually
get out there and say you know what
let's stop politicizing this it just
doesn't seem right okay they would have
so much more credibility go back to July
of 2016 you should have gotten out there
and said you know we we we cheated or
Bernie Sanders out of it he deserved a
fair chance than he got and all of a
sudden what happens is you're creating a
restoration of trust with people where
you're being that bold face in terms of
your honesty and so they're never gonna
do it by the way these operatives on the
Republican side are not gonna do it you
know they're gonna do opposition
research I mean I was on wall street for
29 years and I'm Italian I mean Reince
Priebus thought I had to have done
something wrong Reince Priebus took us
Apple files on you 100% 100% Oppo files
on the company that bought my company
that was his personality he was very
proud of that he was very very separate
issues in terms of the way he did it um
and so I called him out on it I and I at
the anything I'm not a politician so you
went up to because the Washington way to
do it is to smile and say oh yeah so
that's nice Ryan see you for drinks
later yeah yeah no I call them right out
on it and that's the other thing people
say oh well you know you were on the
phone Ryan Lizza saying nasty things
about these guys and you didn't have the
courage to say to their faces that's
totally not true of course I said it to
their faces you know but but at the end
of the day if saying it to their faces
and I've taken some flak for saying it
to their faces but if saying it to their
faces causes a communication disruption
where the American people really start
to understand how these swamp creatures
act yeah maybe the shaming of that will
put some of that to rest and people can
start to subordinate themselves to the
good of the American people actually
serve the American people and so so I'm
hopeful I'm hoping that will happen
two final quick questions if we have
time there was a lot of North Korea talk
in that State of the Union it was an
excellent speech a ji Seon ho a North
Korean defector was invited only god can
judge but Donald Trump can arrange the
meeting is a little Rocketman long for
this world I don't know I my my guess is
is that I like the facts that are
available to me today you know I had
some better insight when I was in the
White House but the facts that are
available to me today is that the North
Korean leadership is talking to the
South Korean leadership and they've
agreed to march together in the Olympics
and they're gonna march under a unified
flag and so I take that as a very strong
positive I think that moon basically
said that it was president Trump's
nature and president Trump's conference
decisiveness and his pushing that got
the two sides together and so I do think
that that's a breakthrough that really
hasn't happened over the last quarter
century they haven't communicated period
it's fun to watch people not want to
give the president credit for that and I
understand why because some of the stuff
that he does is quote unquote
non-presidential but a lot of the stuff
that he does is quite principled right
and so I do think if you're asking me to
make a prediction and that's a terrible
thing to do because you always predict
things that are wrong you know the good
thing about political predictions though
you can predict anything and you'll be
wrong all the time and then people still
do that you mean you swipe the Florida
dollar check from Benton I know we're
very one of the highlights of my
professional career very proud of that
you know that was a prediction of what
your way thank God but but I do think
that there will be a de-escalation there
because it's in the best interest of
everybody I'll say the same thing
about Kim L on that you were saying
about me or a Donald Trump he's getting
caricature iced and he's getting to
dimensionalized
as a cartoon villain which is amazing
maybe the obese guy but he is being a
true to me yes but he may be absolutely
ruthless he may be a horrific in terms
of his morals and his scruples but I
don't think he's dumb and I think he's a
pretty calculating person because he has
survived as a young man in that power
structure after his father died and so
my prediction is he's a rationalist and
he wants to survive he wants that regime
to survive in some form the Hermit
Kingdom and so my prediction is it will
work itself out over - won't he won't
push it so hard that we're gonna take
him out he won't but his button is
probably smaller than the magnets but I
think that goes to that saying that one
on his I believe one of my Marshall can
I get a button on my dad's another funny
comment from the president you know I
mean you got me yeah I love the button
comment final question went how does the
smaller thing and you know in Washington
or in New York for that matter you could
indict a ham sandwich it's very very
easy to do it it seems like Muller
has to get somebody's scalp you can't
just let this thing completely go that
who gets indicted how far up does this
go you know you were talking about this
earlier I do think that the issue now is
going to make people doubly and Triple E
more careful about the situation I think
I think so so I mean look I predict a
positive outcome I'll go back to what
the president said to the New York Times
reporter I think that at mar-a-lago
where he expects this thing to be
resolved in a way that's judicious and
fair to him mm-hmm and I want to I want
to give everybody the benefit of the
doubt that's involved with this thing
and and and say that that will happen I
know that there's a lot of people on the
left that they some part of the
resistance and they want to remove the
president and all this other stuff but
here's I would say you know I mean you
know be careful what you wish for it's a
very common-sense very practical guy I
love vice president Pence I'm not saying
bad against him but here's a guy that's
really rising in power rising in
judgment and the country's doing quite
well earning on the job he's alert he's
getting country tech the country's doing
really quite well so you
should be rooting for you know and and
you know maybe you guys a daily wired
wouldn't like this about me but I went
to law school President Obama and what
he was our president I was rooting for
him because I'm an American and and I
may not agree with you anyway Anthony I
like you know anyway I don't agree with
his policies and I'm certainly debate
his policies and I would go on a
television show or come on a show like
this and explain to you why those
policies are so damaging to the country
but I didn't want us to fail but you
were in law school at the same time as
Barack Obama I was yeah so you got any
juicy gossip I want to hear some don't
yeah this is this is the thing I mean
like I went to law school with them and
like so all the teachers now say that
they taught him which is mathematically
impossible and all the people that were
in law school at the time they was
everything for them but you know I I
didn't I mean I got to know him after
law school frankly but I mean I sort of
vaguely remember him from Law School
justice courses was there at the time it
has Law School rod Rosenstein this a
little bit of trivia was actually in my
section so so that's a person that you
get to know because you're in the same
section together you know it was
Rosenstein again I haven't seen him in
probably in every section I remember
these little sections there's always
this section jerk who knows all the
answers and did all the reading and
there's that guy that gets on everyone I
could tell you that definitely wasn't me
I didn't know the answers I was doing I
wasn't doing enough for the reading I
was playing too much basketball but but
but I remember him being a very quiet
studious guy I just didn't have a
personal relationship with him so I'm
not one of these guys who wants to
exaggerate the relationships for a guy
who's quiet and aloof he probably ended
up at the right at the right place these
days
alright see what happens hopefully I
wish him well and I want I want whatever
is gonna happen now to kind of simmer
down and let's all get on the same side
and let's do what's right for the
American people now I hope when these
cameras go off that Anthony you tell me
about all of the choom gang and hangouts
with Barack Obama in law school but
we'll see we won't be able to get it
while the cameras on Anthony thank you
very much I would have definitely fouled
them more on the basketball court if I
knew the policies back then all right
thank you stay in here man I appreciate
it the mooch is gonna be on Bill Maher
later tonight so check it out is that
gonna be live where's that pre-recorded
I'm not sure it's 10:00 p.m. Eastern
Time 7 p.m. here on the west coast on
HBO I'm pretty sure is
to tape live Detroit or its live a much
film if it's not on just re-watch this
interview you'll get it you'll get a
whole nother round beyond scare emoji yo
it'll be a raucous night I'm sure all
right Donna Brazile will be there with
me she's a good friend
all right Richard House from the Council
of Foreign Relations pretty good crew
all right we'll have to tune in what a
great surprise this is a nice breakfast
and a surprise should I be here
everybody I'm long a lot of kosher food
this morning yeah yeah that's sad to
quote a great man said I'm mikonos this
is the Michael Doyle show tune in Monday
we'll be back then
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Marshall Benson executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey supervising producer Mathis Glover
our technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex zingaro audio is mixed by
Mike Cora Mina hair and makeup is by
Jeshua of era the Michael Noel's show is
a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright for word publishing
2018
you